I'd really like to give big hugs
to all the people who made this
course possible.
That of course includes the whole
production team, especially Amanda,
Catherine, and Morgan,
as well as Charlie and Robert for
their work on the mini projects.
All these good people deserve credit for
the really good parts of the class, and
none of the blame for the less good
parts, which of course falls on moi.
And finally, I want to thank
serial computers everywhere for
their patience and understanding.
[SOUND] Especially when
I was staying up way
past everyone's bedtime,
keeping the lights on.
So with that, I'm out of here, toodles!
Lights out!
Cut.
[MUSIC]
Viva la HPC!